the mother of two missing children will
face a judge in Idaho today after being
extradited to her home state from Hawaii
new video shows Laurie valo and
handcuffs during a layover in Los
Angeles Jonathan Vigliotti is outside
Yellowstone National Park which the FBI
says is now an area of interest
especially in the disappearance of 17
year old Ty Lee Ryan Jonathan good
morning to you why is the focus on
Yellowstone today and good morning to
you Gail police say cellphone data and
photos show that lori valo and her
family visited here but there is no
evidence that Ty Lee Ryan ever left it
the FBI is now calling on everyone that
came to the park on September 8th to
look through their photos for signs of
the family it's been several months and
Lori Velo hasn't said a word about where
her children are lori fallows Hawaiian
honeymoon is over the mother of two
missing children seen arriving in
Rexburg Idaho soon to face a judge 72
miles east in Montana's Yellowstone
National Park the last known image of 17
year old Ty Lee Ryan taken on a family
trip Ty Lee her brother JJ and uncle
Alex Cox also mom Lori valo and JJ JJ's
grandparents Kate and Larry Woodcock on
seeing the photo
if you've seen this truck or the kids on
September 8th the FBI wants to hear from
you the last known images of
seven-year-old JJ came a week later back
in Idaho sources tell CBS News
investigators are also looking into
Valles brother Alex Cox after a series
of mysterious deaths seen here on a
police body camera after fatally
shooting Fallows ex-husband sources say
investigators believe cox is also linked
to the mysterious death of Tammy de Bell
days after her death her husband Chad
married Lori Cox that mysteriously died
in December and Valle will appear in
court later this afternoon the
children's grandparents will also be
there they are the ones that requested
the welfare check that set this
investigation into motion
Anthony Jonathan thank you